Welcome back.
We are now on section four of
our third test, and so we're
on page 530.
And let's start with
problem number one.
If s plus t is equal to 3,
what is the value of s
plus t minus 6?
Well, we know that s plus t is
equal to 3, so they're just
asking us what is 3 minus 6.
Well 3 minus 6 is minus 3.
And that is choice A.
Number two.
They have a box on the cube.
Let me see if I can
draw this box.
So it looks like, and then the
back side's like this, and
then let me draw a little
dotted-- And then the sides
are A-- let me do that in a
different color-- A, B, C, D,
E, P, and Q.
And they say, on the cube in the
figure above, each of the
following points is the same
distance from P as
it is from Q except?
And these are all the choices.
A, B, C, D, and E.
So we want to look for a point
that isn't the same distance
from P as it is from Q.
A is one edge from P and one
edge from Q, so it's not A.
B is two edges from P no
matter how you go.
And it is also two edges from
Q no matter how you go, so
it's not B.
C is one edge from Q, but to get
to P you gotta go at least
three edges.
1, 2, 3, to go to C.
So it's going to be C.
C is much closer to Q than
it is to P, so it is
not the same distance.
So our choice is C.
C is C.
All right.
Problem number three.
And I'll switch to a
less tacky color.
Problem number three.
Oh boy, there's all sorts
of stuff to draw.
Maybe I won't draw it.
Let's see if I can get
by without drawing.
The bar graph above shows where
fraud is committed on
the internet.
Which of the following circle
graphs most accurately
displays the same graph?
Well I'll try it.
So they say websites.
Websites is this huge number.
Websites, that's 78%.
Let me say that that is
this purple color.
Actually I should do this
with the rectangle too.
The websites is a purple color,
and then let's say that
email is, well I'll do it
this color, at 18%.
And then they tell us that news
groups is 2%, so it's a
really small percentage, 2%.
And then finally, they tell
us that other is also 2%.
And then you want to see a pie
graph that's the same thing.
So if this is the pie graph.
So 78% is going to
be this purple,
it's going to be websites.
So that's a little bit
more than 3/4, right?
78% is 3% more than 3/4.
3/4 would look like this.
A little bit more than
3/4 is going to look
something like this.
Oh, oops.
I'm still using the line tool.
But a little bit more than
3/4 is going to look
something like this.
And then I can actually
even fill it.
That's going to be a little
bit more than 3/4.
And then the blue stuff, 18%,
that's going to look
something like 18%.
That's a little less than 25%,
so it's going to be like that.
So we could fill that too.
The other pieces are going to
be these thin slivers like
this, 2% and 2%.
This is really just translating
that into this.
And they're actually going
to be even thinner than
the way I drew it.
And out of all the choices, the
one that has this purple
region, websites, the dark
region on the graph.
The only one that has that,
where it's more than 3/4, are
choices C and D, right?
That's the only one where it
has more than 75% is shaded
the websites' color.
It's either going
to be C or D.
And then when you look at the
difference between C and D,
choice C has nothing
for other in there.
Choice C just has news
groups, no other.
So it has to be D, because
news groups and other are
actually same size.
So they should be the
same proportions.
So the choice is D.
Next problem.
Problem number four.
The numerator of a certain
fraction is 5 less than the
denominator.
So let's say that the
denominator is x.
The numerator is 5 less than
the denominator, so the
numerator is x minus 5.
The numerator is 5 less
than the denominator.
And they say the fraction
is equal to 3/4.
What is the denominator
of this fraction?
So we just solve for x.
So let's cross multiply.
x times 3, so 3x, is equal
4 times x minus 5.
So 3x is equal to 4x minus 20.
And you can subtract.
So you get 20 is equal to,
subtract 3x from both sides,
is equal to x, and that's
the denominator.
So that is choice D.
The next problem has a bunch
of drawing for me to do.
Let's see if I can finish
it in time.
So we have the two axes.
Let me draw the two axes.
This is a big problem,
so I'll draw it big.
I've got the two axes, and then
it goes from k to 6k.
k, 2k, 3k, 4k, 5k, 6k.
6k, 5k, 4k, 3k, you
get the point.
And then it goes from 1 to 6.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And then the triangle looks like
it goes from-- if I were
to draw a line-- it goes
from 2k to 6k, and
then from 2 to 6.
They actually draw the line
like this, 2k it is.
This is a triangle.
I don't know if I'll have time
to do it in this video, but
everything should work out.
The triangle goes from 2k to 5k,
good thing I caught that,
and it's at 0.2.
That's its base.
And then it goes up to
6, where it kind
of is in the middle.
It goes up to here.
This is what the triangle
looks like.
I have redrawn the problem.
And this is B, A, C.
And they say, in the figure
above, the scale on the x-axis
is different from the
scale on the y-axis.
If the area of triangle ABC is
18, what is the value of k?
The area is 18.
So area is equal to 1/2 base
times height for a triangle.
We know that the area is 18.
So 18 is equal to 1/2.
What's the base?
Well we went from 2k to 5k.
So we went 3k.
We went 1, 2, 3.
We went 3k.
So the base is 3k.
And what's the height?
Well from 2 to 6.
So the height is 4, and we
just saw solve for k.
So 18 is equal to 1/2 times 4 is
2 times 3k is equal to 6k.
k is equal to 3.
And that is choice E.
And we are done.
You just have to know area is
equal to 1/2 base times
height, and then just put in the
base, which is 3k, and the
height, and solve for k.
I'll see you in the
next video.